hi dina
hi martin how's it going
going great because today we are
designing an application that deals with
money i hear oh oh yeah that's true
for our event planners
right uh so it's gonna be serverless
application that deals with money we're
gonna go through exactly what products
you use in this thing are you ready i am
let's do it
[Music]
okay
so we have
three users
we have our event planners our
accountants and our vendors and our
event planners need to
register the vendors
they need to create purchase orders so
that the vendors deliver whatever it is
that they're delivering
the accountants need to view and improve
invoices so the vendors get paid and the
vendors need to be able to submit their
invoices
very good so i see we have them here on
the left hand side looking good and
let's see some of these are inside our
company some are outside huh yes exactly
we can think of this as like two groups
like one's like internal and one is
external
got it and the internal ones that's it
looks like event planners and
accountants
yeah exactly so
we're you know we're going to build a
web app um
but yeah it's worth starting by thinking
how are we going to ensure
that only the people inside our company
access this web app
ah right so for a project i recently was
on we used identity aware proxy for that
it is super simple to set things up that
people within our domain they get in
nobody everybody else is kept outside
and you can even set levels within that
but but yeah for this super easy let's
do it identity aware proxy awesome okay
so the next question is
what do we use for the web app
yeah
right it's a web app okay serving html
javascript and so on uh yeah i think app
engine would work well here you and i
both know app engine well um it's also
uh on again on my last project it was
like a two or three click integration to
put it together with identity web proxy
even better and super classic love it
okay
this is easy
so we're done
no okay
next we come to
possibly the first difficult decision um
we have to start thinking about storage
because the event planners are going to
be you know
filling out a form and saying these are
the vendors and that needs to go
somewhere
and
i i like to think about storage options
always as
relational databases versus
non-relational databases
and in this case you know we're talking
about
um i'm talking about money and we're
talking about
these are the purchase orders and then
these are the invoices and we're going
to need to be able to
to run reports against these things say
like you know this is like the money
that we've pledged this is the money
that we've paid
and so for something like that i really
think that we absolutely have to use a
relational database
yeah i agree uh
for like you're saying sum up uh like a
thousand documents a thousand invoices
and get their sum super easy and quick
to do uh in and i think uh we could do
spanner we could do various other things
i think cloud sql is the right here
because we will have on the order of you
know
gigabytes not terabytes or petabytes
here so cloud sql which is well known
you and i both familiar with mysql and
postgres so that'll be easy oh my gosh i
feel like it's 2010 app engine with a
cloud sql database i love it
yeah well-known technology
okay cool so
uh let's see everybody's go oh no
vendors aren't connected to anything
yes okay so the first thing that we need
to think about is
is the fact that they are external and
they're coming from anywhere and
possibly
possibly everywhere um so how do we
ensure that they are able to access
our service
and do appropriate things on the service
but nobody else is
right so we need to know that they are
who they say they are and and so on i
think for that identity platform is a
great choice because then they can log
in with their gmail accounts or from
various other identity providers they
can log in
self-service set up their own accounts
but we do know who is who if somebody
logs in as fluffybunny at gmail.com we
know that that really is fluffy bunny
the vendor or
sonomawinery.com maybe
more likely
yes
so identity platform there i think that
that's a shoe and that would be easy to
do but
now what platform serves up html and
javascript and css to them yeah i think
let's go with app engine again um you
know we don't
i don't think that we need to do cloud
run for this because
you know we're not using any special
runtimes or or you know anything
that like that i think just your
standard app engine would work great
yep i agree i love cloud run but if it's
smart to keep it to only one product
here for computing
uh okay so these folks upload uh
invoices it says here submit invoice pdf
is that what the vendors are doing
oh
yes okay so
um
we always need to consider that we need
to meet our users where they are
and in this case our event planners work
with vendors from all over the place
sometimes it's like a giant hotel chain
um that has like very standardized
systems that can plug and play really
easily with whatever we want
and then sometimes it's you know mom and
pop from a sonoma vineyard and they're
gonna
maybe send their invoice on the back of
a postcard i don't know
or they even fax them sometimes so yeah
we need a system that
allows the vendors to to keep using
whatever system works for them um
maybe it's a pdf um maybe they you know
have like a hand written invoice and you
know it'd be really cool if they could
just like you know take a picture and
upload it yeah with their phone right
yeah yes yes exactly
um which means we're back to the storage
question
uh
but this time
you know it's not
columns and rows it's not numbers it's
it's bytes you know it's um
it's rather
yeah binary files right yeah and and i
mean we could theoretically store them
in a relational database
but they are products that are better at
it right yes yeah and you know
we don't want to store them
you know for too long either um so
i was thinking that maybe we could use
something like storage bucket a cloud
storage bucket
i love that google cloud storage because
you said we don't want to keep them
around for too long
on a previous project i worked we set
things up so after six months you can do
this very easily with a few clicks in
cloud storage after six months
uh delete the files
so it's nice and clean everything's
automated you have automated controls
yes this is good
yes and you can set like kind of like
granular permissions per storage bucket
so i think using cloud storage is really
great
are we done all right so the picture the
vendor took a picture with a cell phone
of the postcard that written their uh
invoice on they send it up it's now
sitting in a storage bucket in google
cloud storage now what
we need to get this data
from the bucket
somehow
into cloud sql um
so we we don't want to have a system
where somebody's got to like log in and
look at all these images and then like
you know
input it
into a form because that's
well what's going to happen is like it's
just going gonna
take for like take forever like it's
gonna sit there for a really long time
people are gonna make mistakes
um and then the vendors are gonna get
really angry when their payments are
super late so right
i think we need to do some kind of event
driven development here so that as soon
as the image goes into the storage
bucket
something happens
that starts us um on our you know in our
pipeline
into the cloud sql
what do you think okay
yeah i like that and we can easily set
up a cloud function to do that so if if
a new document drops in this bucket then
trigger this cloud function and the
cloud function gets the
the document
so and can work on it okay so the cloud
function now has access to this
image taking a pdf or
image taken with the phone and now we
need to pull data out of that how do we
do that
with machine learning
of course but
i like your enthusiasm but i'm not
really a machine learning expert to dina
oh my gosh neither am i but the great
thing is you don't have to be now oh
we use machine learning not just because
it's cool because it's a buzzword
machine learning is is the tool to use
when you need to make decisions on
things that you don't know about yet um
you have seen examples of it in the past
and you need your system to be able to
look at it and make a decision without
having an exact recipe a list of steps
to follow and so
this is a perfect example because we
don't know
what fields are going to be on this form
we don't know if they're going to be
like writing little handwritten messages
with like hearts on it um we so we need
some kind of machine learning api to be
able to go in and parse the information
now luckily google has a lot of products
that
that already have pre-built models for
you because i do not want to go in and
you know build my own model for this
google has probably seen far more
documents than you or i have seen or can
come up with yeah exactly exactly and
you know i don't have the time to to
collect a million examples to be able to
train a new api so i think we should use
um the vision api because the vision api
has a feature that lets you parse forms
excellent cool so vision api there we
run that and then the output of that is
like
it can tell things like tax was a
hundred dollars uh the total was five
hundred dollars that sort of thing you
pull lots properties
exactly exactly so like it'll go through
and i'll find the labels and then i'll
find the values and then you have this
this you know
structured data um
but the the only thing is like we need
to be careful about like trying to put
this directly into
something like a relational database
because if you don't know
all the fields that are going to be on
the form in advance
ah right uh i think i am the just the
right thing so we'll we we have
documents right with certain properties
we don't know exactly what properties
there is a database product built for
that uh firestore it's a document
database so each document can have
different uh properties from other
documents as well so it's sort of semi
it's more
ordered than just an image but it's not
as strictly uh ordered as a sql database
perfect perfect okay so then um
it it you know we have the event
triggering the cloud function uh the
vision api looks at it and says hey you
know this is the the name of the event
this is the vendor this is how much it
cost it puts all that into firestore and
then when our accountants log on to our
app engine web app uh we'll pull up that
document that from firestore and then
they'll be able to look at it and
they'll be able to approve it or to be
able to you know like edit it slightly
um you know maybe look at the image and
say like oh no this wasn't for
um
mom and pop vineyard this was for
uh
sonoma i don't know
right or one image one number was a
little smudged uh and then in that one
out of 100 cases they can go in and
tweak it yeah i like that and that would
do that from app engine and you said
then that feeds into sql right then
we're done yay i like this it's sort of
order out of chaos yeah chaotic data
comes in and gradually gets more ordered
along the way and finally it's order
enough for the accountants to issue
payment yeah yeah no yeah the great
thing is that there's these two
different work streams um
one
is just your very very classic
app engine cloud sql and then the other
really takes advantage of all of these
like
new you know event driven and machine
learning and firestore all these like
new technologies and ways of coding and
ways of thinking and then we put them
together and like you say order out of
chaos
thank you everybody for watching if you
would like to see me or dina design
another serverless app please let us
know in the comments or if you have
questions about this one
also let us know what other topics you
would like to see in this video series
about serverless computing
until next time
[Music]